[Music]
joining me now is utah congressman
burgess owens in florida congresswoman
cat kamik
thank you so much for joining us tonight
i really really do believe i really do
appreciate it uh congressman uh owen
said let me let me go to you first how
do you react to that because i gotta
tell you they i get a lot of preaching
from the party that's supposed to be you
know the one of the people and for
democracy
the people who say they're the most
tolerant seem to be the least tolerant
of any sort of divergent thought well
first of all jason what a great model i
would start us off
let me just
say this
just think about what how you feel and
listen to these people
the democratic party unfortunately says
to good democrats who have found
themselves still in the party which i
ended up leaving decades ago it's about
division it's about hatred by anger uh
they do everything they can to make
people miserable miserable miserable
miserable so they can gain uh gain their
power and that's what you see in the
black communities uh the inner city
communities throughout our country what
you see there is what they project for
the rest of our country
misery uh which uses a political
strategy to to win their power so we're
waking up and i think that's scaring
them to death because we're now
realizing as i'm seeing across the
country black's expanding space
across the board it doesn't matter what
our race and background is we're
realizing that we don't want to be uh
demean and depressed we want hope that's
what our country's all about and we're
drifting back to the parties they're
going to give back to to the rest of
this country
yeah congresswoman they the the
democratic party of today has really
become one of division it's just what
congressman owens is saying is they they
they continually divide and demean and
degrade people and and think they're
stupid i mean they flat out say it
there's james carville saying yeah deb
republicans are just republican voters
are stupid
well that's exactly it jason and you
know it's always good to see you and my
good friend burgess you know think about
this the gop is not the grand old party
we are the great opportunity party we
stand for freedom for for everyone
regardless of your background regardless
of where you come from and that is the
opportunity that the gop is fighting to
protect and uphold but when you look at
our colleagues to the left it's do as i
say not do as i do everything they say
is for quote unquote democracy and
freedom yet every policy that they have
championed and passed out of the house
this past year and a half has been
anything but they voted to defund police
and make our communities less safe they
have voted to take away our second
amendment rights again while
simultaneously defunding police they
have an open border policy they think
that there's no problem with fentanyl
that's become the number one killer of
people between the ages of 18 and 45 and
as the youngest republican woman in
congress today i am supposed to be what
they would deem a victim they want to
victimize my generation but now we have
people like me someone who's the
daughter of a single mother someone who
has gone from homeless to the house of
representatives in under a decade not
because of democratic policies but
because i am championing the freedom
that the gop
has upheld that is what we need to be
fighting for and by the way to all our
colleagues on the left we do not have a
democracy we have a constitutional
republic so let's act like it
yeah no it's a good point they always
tend to forget that yeah that's actually
how it works but they go out and they
preach a good game and they try to
demonize those who believe in for
instance the 10th amendment which gives
states the rights congressman owens uh
do they they don't actually really
believe in that 10th amendment and they
want to centralize as much power
in in washington dc right
no the left does not believe no
constitution that's why they continue to
try to tear down let me just give kudos
to american people something that i
don't think many of us realize that
happened we had a miracle the last
turnaround even though we lost the
senate the house of presidency
we flipped as a country 15 seats in
janelle who's one incumbent you see
people like myself and kevin of new
congress people that represent this new
congress that is all about america first
we're not we're not ashamed of who we
are but we're not ashamed of our past we
we talk about how we're going to be
inclusive to each other this is the new
republican party and we have an
opportunity let's go around to add on to
that i'm excited about where our country
is i'm excited that the fact our country
is waking up to the lies of the left and
all you have to do is again look back on
the history and the damage is done to
the black community that i grew up in
and we don't want any parts of that so
let's continue to realize there is good
and there's there's bad and the
democratic party's brought nothing but
bad to our country as long as they've
been around
yeah i remember a vice president pence
would often say
congresswoman he would also often say
look i'm a conservative i'm not angry
about it i i'm a happy person and
but you know what the left doesn't seem
to believe in self-determination and
they seem to be awfully mad at anybody
who thinks anything different than they
do
well and that's exactly it jason you
know when i talk about how i was
supposed to be one of their targets i'm
their target demographic i'm a college
educated woman and they want to
basically own
certain demographics in this country if
you're a minority you supposedly have to
vote democrat if you're a college
educated woman you have to vote democrat
if you're gen z or millennial they want
you and demand that you vote democrat
because they're all about checking boxes
they're all about quote-unquote
diversity except for when it comes to
diversity of thought they want to be the
thought police and it's group think and
it's dangerous and we're seeing the
result of that kind of action in
washington take no look further than
your local gas pump or your grocery
store their economic policies have
failed their national security policies
have failed that is why november is
going to be a resounding win for
republicans it's because we are about
faith family freedom it's because we're
about that opportunity and we're going
to secure the border we're going to
lower gas prices we're going to get our
communities safe again and we're going
to put america first and we're not going
to continue to perpetuate the stereotype
that everyone is a victim we're about
empowerment we are about giving the
opportunity to every individual
regardless of where they come from and
so i think that we speak with actions
while the left speaks with words and i
think the american people are smart
enough to figure out what's up at the
end of the day
yeah i've never seen a party prevail for
a long term when they just demonize and
and call the voters stupid i don't think
that's a great strategy but that's where
the democrats of today are congressman
owens con congresswoman came back i wish
i had more time but i got to go so thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else